بمرور الساعات تتهاوى هدنه السودان
الجديده بدل ان تتماسك من الخروق التي
المت بها مبكرا انها في اليوم الثاني تبدو
كسابقاتها عائله الى الانهيار رغم استناد
وقف اطلاق النار هذه المره الى اليه رقابه
لقد تجددت الاشتباكات في عده مناطق
بالخرطوم بينها ام درمان حيث اسقطت قوات
الدعم السريع طائره حربيه للجيش السوداني
اوضحت مقاطع مصوره حطامها وسط النار
والدخان كما اعلنت الدعم السريع اسرها احد
الطيارين اللذين تمكنان من القفز من
المقاتله وقد جاء حادث ام درمان في اعقاب
تحليق كثيف للطائرات وقصف عنيف بالمدافع
والدبابات في المنطقه
انفجارات قويه دوت ايضا في مناطق شرق
النيل وكافور بمدينه بحري تزامنا مع
اشتباكات عنيفه بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع في احياء بوسط الخرطوم بينما اكد
الجيش استعاده مطابعي سك العمله غربيه
العاصمه من سيطره من وصفهم بالمتمردي
الذين اتهمهم بنهب مخسون الدوله من النقد
واحتياط بنك السودان من الذهب
كان من المفترض ان تستمر الهده الجديده
اسبوعا وهي برعايه ومراقبه امريكيه سعوديه
حتى ان واشنطن لوحت بمحاسبه منتهكيها وفرض
عقوبات قاسيه عليهم ومع ان تطورات الساعات
الاخيره في الخرطوم لا تؤشر الى اي التزام
او ارتداع وتزداد بذلك حيره السودانيين
وهم تحت القصف من تلك الحدود الفاصله بين
نجاح الهدنه وانهيارها لكن انتهاك الهدنه
الذي يتريث السياسيون في الاقرار به كان
صداه سريعا في اروقه الامم المتحده بجنيف
ما نشهده اليوم في السودان يدمل القلب انا
اتحدث مع السودانيين وعلى تواصل معهم
وكانت تلك مهمه الاولى كنت في السودان ولا
استطيع ان اتخيل الحياه في الخرطوم في هذه
الاثناء لذلك فان التضامن يجب ان يكون مع
الشعب السوداني
والمشهد اكثر سوءا بالارقام اذ اعلنت
منظمه الهجره الدوليه نزوح اكثر من مليون
شخص داخل السودان منذ اندلاع القتال منتصف
ابريل الماضي كما لجا نحو 30020 الفا
اخرين الى دول مجاوره وكثير منهم ما
يزالون عالقين على المعابر وفي مخيمات
ايواء تفتقر لابسط مستلزمات العيش